the Florida manatee estate symbol once
on the verge of extinction has made a
big comeback manatees were recently
reclassified from endangered to a
threatened species somewhere the
enormous mammals will lose special
protections they need to save them from
their number one threat people mark
Strassmann is at Lowry Park Zoo in Tampa
with how boaters are putting the
restored manatee population at risk mark
good morning
good morning this tank is part of the
manatee hospital here the two men ''tis
in it both needed critical care after
they were hit by boats the vets here
heal them but first they often just have
to try to keep them alive the larger
debate here is whether manatees should
still be classified and protected as an
endangered species Florida manatees are
gentle giants about ten to twelve feet
long averaging 1,300 pounds raising
slowly on plants in shallow waters along
the state's coast so what I'm looking
for now is any kind of movement in the
water Mike Dunn helped us find a handful
of them man tease right there about
three o'clock it took them 10 minutes
because they swim right behind his house
in Crystal River Florida where his
charter boat takes out tourists I really
do care about their great gentle
creature they remind me that Volkswagen
in the early 60s a Volkswagen was really
ugly but every bill fell in love with
the manatees the same thing but in
Florida fast boaters repeatedly mow down
manatees propellers gash gouge and maim
hundreds of them a year bigger boats cut
them in half ray Ball is the senior vet
at Tempest Lowry Park Zoo which treats
wounded manatees and last year set a
record we admitted 37 manatees the
majority of those were due to boat
strike
sometimes the injuries are actually
quite catastrophic in 1967 Florida
manatees were listed by the federal
government as an endangered species at
that time roughly 600 were alive since
then their population has spiked to
about 6600 enough progress that last
month they were reclassified as
threatened the animals were out here
being killed
kind of
one after another that road should be
celebrating the reclassification right
he's not this aquatic biologist is also
executive director of the nonprofit save
the manatee Club
why is the reclassification likely to
hurt rather than help it can hurt if
it's not scientifically and by and also
legally justified so then you start to
pull back protections which they say
they're not going to do but we know
there are user groups that want the law
is reduced and they want to be able to
run their boats faster as a practical
matter what difference does it make the
amount of money that goes into
protecting endangered species is often
more than what goes into a threatened
species as the manatee herd here has
grown over the last four decades
Florida's human population has also
boomed Mike Dunn's on the water nearly
every day protecting manatees from his
other neighbors the ones in boats will
you shout at another boater if he's not
doing it right I have no problem shout
into somebody they're always in the
wrong spot and they're going too fast
they're going too fast what we try to
tell and educate people is if you hit a
manatee please call it in we might be
able to find him and save them many
manatees are hit repeatedly by boats
experts estimate that 80% of manatees
will be hit at least once something else
to consider these manatees both are
doing well experts here have high hopes
they can be re-released into the wild
Martin Lee thank you so much that's good
advice at least if you hit them call
somebody they they could pause it can
you save them they can do something I
love the comparison